after a rebound in travel this summer
people are once again cancelling plans
for trips because of the surging number
of covet cases in a recent survey 27 of
respondents said they had postponed a
trip again and more than 54 said that
the delta variant has made them less
interested in traveling right now errol
barnett has more from reagan national
airport he's right outside washington
d.c errol everybody wants to go
somewhere but now we're starting to get
scared again tugo good morning to you
you know it good morning to you and we
totally understand it's really an
emotional balancing act so many people
are experiencing
right now on one hand they're desperate
to reconnect with friends they haven't
seen in a very long time and head out to
a big event but on the other hand the
pandemic is raging once again so we
spoke with two women who who truly
struggled with what to do
it was really kind of heartbreaking to
not be able to finally go on wednesday
cotton star of houston was expecting to
see her friends in san diego for the
first time in a long time it's been
uh
basically two years now since i've been
able to see them kim hof outside denver
has been waiting even longer planning to
meet her friends at dragoncon a pop
culture convention in atlanta next month
when it got to the point of the rates
just skyrocketing in the last week or so
i thought no i'm sorry there's no level
of logistics that will make me feel okay
if i bring this back with me
both cancelled their long-awaited trips
due to the spread of the delta variant
the highly transmissible strain of covid
accounting for most new cases which
soared nationwide over the past two
months
it wasn't just the rates in atlanta
the rates are getting worse here in
colorado and who knows how many people
you're going to pass in the airport
airfare is on the downtrend economist
addict demotaron with the travel app
hopper says summer flight demand has
flattened from pandemic highs which is
now leading to lower prices but his
service is finding since july one aspect
of travel is up there's been a 33
increase in people buying cancelable
tickets people want to have that option
to cancel if for any reason you know
something happens the situation develops
in a way where they can't take that trip
another potential pitfall airlines
cutting flights in june and july
domestic air cancellations were above
their one percent average which
translates to ten thousand cancellations
in july alone spirit american and other
carriers suffering from staffing bad
weather and other issues leaving people
like star concerned to help manage her
lupus she takes immunosuppressants i'm a
high-risk category so i was a little
concerned with
what was going to happen during that
travel i was going to be exposed to a
lot of people
a lot of kind of angry people on the
airplanes didn't really want to get
involved with that the worst case
scenario made her cancel her plans our
hospitals are filling up so fast and
we're one of the largest medical centers
in the nation i don't know if there will
be room if i have to end up going hoff's
ailing grandfather led her to change her
mind i've been
keeping in the back of my mind i might
need to make a short notice trip to see
him
and if i take the risk for anything
you know it should be family
that's a good point now cotton did not
purchase a cancelable ticket but her
airline southwest is offering her a
credit for a future flight hoff did
purchase flight insurance which is
always a good idea and she hopes to
recoup her costs taking that avenue but
for all the people cancelling their
travel plans a sizable number still
expect to head out according to a recent
survey anthony 26 of respondents say
they do in fact plan to take a trip come
october yeah it's a it's a really tricky
decision errol thank you yeah i mean i
think everybody you're thinking about it
too october too having second thoughts
you know it's very hard to be an airline
right now yeah sure how many people are
going to show up and i hear the airlines
are trying to be accommodating too
because they understand
who thought last summer we'd still be
doing this this summer but here we are